[Music]
action sub reporter Christine pay is at
the scene with what we know
apparently we don't have that story
right now astronomers at the University
investigation in Southwest Albert C you
can
see what up yo I'm Dave Ruben this is
the Ruben report it is February 8th 2024
we're live streaming on Rumble locals
and YouTube we've got a Ruben report
Community Q&A if you want to get a
question in on the Fly Ruben report.
locals.
and you can ask me anything as the kids
do on the internet I'm running out of
air uh the theme of today's show is that
normal people continue to wake up and I
really want to make that a theme of the
show going forward if anyone anywhere be
it a football star a
podcaster a politician a janitor or a
shoe salesman if they start waking up
for whatever reason and starts speaking
out and it starts getting traction those
are the voices that I want to amplify
because I keep telling you guys it's not
about this right left thing it's not
liberal conservative it's basically kind
of roughly sane people who may not agree
on every little thing like abortion or
taxes or whatever but kind of believe in
Freedom and decency and that think
America and all that stuff is good it's
us vers everybody else and I want to
amplify the people that are doing that
uh at at the very not only right this
moment but I want to I want to do it so
that the dam will break and more and
more of us will speak up because I think
there are way more of us and they've
effectively silenced us and you got to
give them credit uh when they've done
that because it has worked and that's
why we are kind of at the place that we
are at right now so we're going to talk
a little bit about football star Aaron
Rogers who was on Joe Rogan yesterday
who's he's just gone through such an
incredible red pilling just so fast
Rogan's gone through I would say a bit
of a slower red pilling but it's
happened to him we're going to connect
that to the new El Salvador well the not
new he's been a uh prime minister for a
couple years now president uh naib
buelli who just got reelected and he is
totally redpilled and you can sort of
see how the media treats people who want
you to think for yourself and uh not
just be obedient to the machine so
that's what we will be doing on the
program today get yourself some popcorn
and get ready to go but first let's talk
about tax Network USA guys are you
struggling with your back taxes or
unfiled Returns the IRS is escalating
collections adding 20,000 new agents and
sending over 5 million collection
letters to kick off this year in these
challenging times your best defense is
tax Network USA don't let the IRS take
advantage of you with over 14 years of
experience tax Network USA has saved
their clients over a billion in back
taxes no matter the size of your tax
issue their expertise is your advantage
they specialize in negotiating with the
IRS aiming to significantly reduce your
debt tax Network USA doesn't just
negotiate they also protect your assets
from IRS seizures and manage your yearly
returns for ongoing compliance
importantly they are licensed to help
you with all state tax issues regardless
of where you live in the US the clock is
ticking don't wait as the IRS steps up
its game seize control of your financial
future now contact tax Network USA for
immediate relief and expert guidance
call 1800 245 6000 or visit TN
usa.com dve don't let tax issues
overpower you turn to tax Network USA
and find your path to financial peace
peace of mind okay so what did I just
say a moment ago for those of you paying
attention normal people waking up people
who are not particularly political who
then make some choice about what they
want to be injected with or how much
they want to pay in taxes or whether
they want to live in a country that has
a border and next thing you know they're
bigots and racists and homophobes and
everything else that is the group of
people I'm interested in Aaron Rogers uh
of course major football star is one of
them and we've played a bunch of clips
of him over the last couple months cuz
he's been going went through this red
pilling process which had a lot to do
with covid but it wasn't just Co because
he started speaking out against covid
and then of course what happened the
mainstream media started going after him
he's a conspiracy theorist he shouldn't
be allowed to play in the NFL he's
dangerous he's also a racist etc etc
anyway he went on Joe Rogan yesterday to
talk about big Pharma and how they
control the narrative the problem with
that is to control the messaging yes Ian
they are controlling the message so if
if somebody went after that and said hey
you're not going to be allowed to
advertise on TV anymore cuz I think
we're one of the only countries maybe
there's one other country New Zealand's
the only other country okay so there's
two countries it would be you know they
would be attacked for anti-science or or
whatever it might be what what RFK wants
to do um you know kind of the
dismantling or the re- uh forming
realigning of the CDC and NIH and some
of these alphabet companies who've been
uh lying and misleading the public for
so long
you know he would get absolutely
slaughtered by by the media why not
because they actually believe that but
because who's paying them yes it's those
companies so they control the message so
when when you come out and talk about
you know what you use to heal yourself
during Co or when I come out and talk
about or Dr Peter Mulla or Robert Malone
or insert anybody who was just trying to
GRE pet Cory they get absolutely
railroaded and censored and silenced and
attacked and slandered it's not I mean
it's not the news it's corporate
controlled it's completely controlled
and it's it's not good for us and the
fact that people went along with it
because they thought ideologically that
that group of people aligned with their
side and the other side was Donald Trump
and the Maga and the vaccine deniers and
all all the craziness that they
attributed to that I mean it's really
kind of brilliant the way they've pushed
this propaganda but at the end of the
day it's not beneficial to to the
greater good of society right so I know
you guys know all that already at this
point of course when he talks about
controlling the messaging we've shown
you that compilation video many times
during covid how they'd be covering
covid on NBC News CNN uh ABC Etc and
then they'd cut to commercial brought to
you by fizer and it's like oh really so
you're taking money from the very people
who are you are supposed to be
objectively talking about and and
criticizing where criticism is due it's
etc etc so it is bought and controlled
and of course what Rogan hits on at the
end there is also right that you know
unfortunately so many people went all in
on Donald Trump and the conservatives
and the Republicans are all racists and
maniacs and they hate everybody and
everything else that that liberal chunk
of people let's say or the sort of
mainstream chunk of people they were
just like oh we'll just trust the
experts because at least they're not
them and the experts the entire expert
class basically made up a whole bunch of
stuff they made up they had to redefine
the word vaccine because this vaccine
didn't actually vaccinate you uh 6- foot
social distancing made no sense the
lockdowns made no sense all of those
things and if you haven't seen my
interview yet from just two days ago uh
in DC with Senator ran Paul he talks
about how when where uh um Aaron Rogers
is talking about these alphabet
companies the NIH CDC etc etc what Ram
Paul talks about is everyone's still
there nobody's been fired right like
bouch's gone he retired but he's still
influential in that world obviously but
after all of this stuff there was no
Reckoning so RFK Jr or Ronda santis the
guys that wanted the Reckoning doesn't
look like they're going to get it
unfortunately that's how the swamp
operates anyway they uh continued to
talk a bit more about how the mainstream
media no we're gon to drop this one what
what oh yeah yeah yeah they continue to
talk about a bit more about how the
mainstream media covers these things and
look what the mainstream media uh did
when Joe Rogan announced he had Co and
how he was going to take care of himself
and turns out I got Co so we immediately
threw the kitchen sink out all kinds of
meds monoclonal antibodies uh
Ivermectin
zpac uh prednizone
everything did you catch what CNN did
right there did you see the color of Joe
Rogan's face on the CNN version of that
he looked completely fine and normal and
had a reddish Hugh uh when he went on
his experimental
medications uh and uh when CNN put him
on he was green so this is just another
way that they do all these things and by
the way then what happened at the exact
same time as all of this was unfolding
suddenly for two weeks the entire
mainstream media was calling Joe Rogan
racist because they Unearthed videos of
him saying the nword even though as you
know he was not saying it in a racist
way he was saying it to mock the people
who actually are racist uh but who's
been the number one guy going after
Aaron Rodgers as Aaron Rodgers has woke
up well it is uh I would say government
mouthpiece quote unquote comedian Jimmy
Kimmel and you may remember this one
from his show at the height of Co this
this is one like if you look at all of
the late night crap that we can show you
and throwback to during Co this might be
the single worst moment Dr foui said
that if hospitals get any more
overcrowded they're going to have to
make some very tough choices about who
gets an ICU bet I that Metro doesn't
seem so tough to me vaccinated person
having a heart attack yes come right on
him and we'll take care of you
unvaccinated guy who gobbled horse goo
rest in peace Wheezy you're think of the
level of evil that I know you've seen
that clip before I mean that is deeply
deeply evil it's against the hipocratico
and we now know that the vaccines didn't
even work and the heart attack that the
vaccinated person might be having might
have been because of uh the vaccine in
the first place so who's a worse person
who got more of the stuff wrong
and wanted to take out their anger
throughout all of this on other people
is it Aaron Rogers and Joe Rogan or is
it a guy like Jimmy Kimmel uh anyway
Aaron Rogers continued yesterday to talk
about what's the motivation of the
people who did things like Jimmy Kimmel
yeah it's just on and on and on through
this whole thing my thing is this is you
know all of us who've been attacked for
our
position to all those people what do you
think the motivation is yeah I mean I
you know just look at my own situation
like I lost friends allies in the media
millions of dollars in
sponsorship because I talked about what
worked for me and my own beliefs and my
own health reasons why I didn't get
vaccinated oh by the way you were right
yeah you were right look you didn't need
it look how quickly you recovered you
fine and same with you yeah and what did
they do they changed the color of your
face they they vilified all early
treatments including a medicine that's
has one of the safest profiles out there
that the we've talked about the guy who
invented it got a Noel prize they were
using it all over the world in U Pradesh
in Africa and various places and that's
what you do during the pandemic right
you find ways to repurpose drugs for
early treatments but no they couldn't do
that because if there's an early
treatment then they can't get the UA
can't do this proven to have
antiviral properties yeah but what's the
motivation for Peter McCulla who got
vilified what's the motivation for Rober
Malone like well if you know Peter
McCulla Peter McCulla is like that guy
has standards and morals and ethics I
mean he is a rock solid and he actually
treated patients too actually treated
patients he's also the most published
doctor in history yeah in his particular
field of study the point of all of this
guys is that when you stand up there is
going to be a cost obviously it quite
literally cost Aaron roders millions of
dollars at the height of covid I could
not go into Studios and do interviews
with people right I have no doubt it
cost sponsorship and all those things
did I largely become right about Co and
vaccines and everything else yes and
then over time in the last two plus
years our show has grown and grown and
grown and grown because then people were
like oh Dave seems like he's roughly a
trustworthy guy and kind of at least
directionally get things right so I'll
tune into that right so you win over
time the truth does work over time but
it but it's it's messy and it's banged
up as it's happening but I I would also
add when they ask like why do these
people do these things you have to
understand a guy like Jimmy Kimmel or a
guy like Steven coar or any of these
late night Comics or these actors who
did all the videos you know saying if
you don't get backx we're not going to
work with you and you're evil and all
that stuff they're just interchangeable
parts there's nothing that special about
Jimmy Kimmel or stepen colar or any of
these guys you could have any two- bit
comedian do their job right because
they're reading off a script and yeah
there's a skill to reading off a
teleprompter and you know they've got a
bunch of writers that make them look
funny and there I won't say that there's
no Talent there there's a degree of
talent there but it's a very
interchangeable part so you have to bow
to the system as as a corporate comic
right you think you think Jimmy Kimmel
if the powers that be over at ABC during
covid had been you know if he if his
personal ethics had been against it he
would have been like I'm not going to do
that they would have been like all right
you're fired so he was like yes I do
like making 20 million dollar a year and
I don't begrudge him that I begrudge him
I suppose the way that it uh I don't
know went directly oppositional to the
truth uh anyway a bit more just on why
you should stand up because that is the
theme of everything that I try to talk
about on the show in the back of their
head they know you weren't nearly as
nutty as they thought you were yeah I
mean I think as more research comes out
there's more papers published in very
reputable scientific um Publications
that talk about you know all the things
that I I was kind of stopping for and
talking about I think in the end there's
a you you're on a decision you you stand
for something you stand courageously for
what you believe in or the opposite side
of that is uh either saying nothing or
being a coward and I wasn't willing to
do that now say whatever you want about
the way I went about doing it
um in the end I made a decision that was
best for me and I'm going to continue
talking about this stuff because it's
important to me and I don't want uh the
memories to be lost I don't want what I
went through to get uh brushed over
um and also I don't give a you know I've
I've been able to make a ton of money
playing a sport that I'm really good at
and I'm thankful for that uh I have a
platform some people want you to just
shut up and be throw a football and
that's fine but um I think there has to
be certain voices of reason and many
people say I'm an idiot I don't have I'm
not smart I got attacked for my
intelligence levels which is interesting
angle to attack me on there's a lot of
things you can say about me but um
that's that's an interesting angle to go
but in the end um I believe that what I
did and what I stand for uh
is uh is a tough position to be in but I
think it's important responsibility to
continue to speak up and use my voice um
to give other people the permission to
stand up as well because there's a lot
of people that believe a lot of the
things that I believe in that don't have
the opportunity to do it don't have have
the courage to do it don't have the
platform to do it in and I feel like I
can speak for some of those people and
hold a line for them it's it's quite
well said and even the way he speaks
like the Communist it's just so clearly
it's obviously true it's what he
believes and everything else I do want
to reference you know when he talks
about people mocking him for his
intelligence you know it's so
interesting because if you think back to
the two or three crazy years of covid it
was all of the intelligent people wasn't
it all of the really really smart people
who wanted to believe the science and
then who went all in on a whole bunch of
stuff as I referenced earlier that we
now know didn't work the vaccines did
not work and all of the vaccine injuries
that subsequently have happened I mean
you in your own life person watching
this through the screen right now like
don't you feel like more and more people
are getting sick in weird ways like I
know a whole bunch of people that have
had weird health things since the
vaccine I am I am so thrilled that we
decided not to get the vaccine but I
have loved ones and family members who
ultimately did it we all had our own
pressures and you know it it in its
weird way it has nothing to do with
whether you're smart or not whether you
trust this stuff it also goes to your
temperament how much will you be pushed
and and at what point do you finally
decide to push back I remember for me
when we were getting pretty damn close
to doing it I didn't want to do it I
thought the whole thing was rushed out I
didn't like anything about it and I felt
that we were young and relatively
healthy and take care of ourselves and
eat right and lived in Cali where we
could get sunshine and all of that stuff
uh but we were getting all sorts of
pressures just like everybody else and I
was like am I ever going to go to a
restaurant again and well I see my
family and all of those things and then
I remember when when the government came
in and started saying this was the Biden
Administration when they started having
these mandates for companies and I was
sitting in in the studio in LA with
Connor who's still here and Michael my
former producer and the idea that me as
an employee that I would have some uh
right over them to tell them what they
have to inject themselves with I was
like that's completely psychotic you owe
me one Connor whatever happened to that
Michael guy who knows but but like that
was completely psychotic and and these
were all the things that we allowed to
happen and it was the smart people who
went in on it you know the quote unquote
smart people so it has very little to do
with intelligence what they're really
trying to do is insult your ability to
think for yourself so I want to connect
that to to one other thing uh that's
happening in the world right now which
is that uh there was an election in El
Salvador and president naiv buk uh was
reelected but I want to show you some of
the headlines now buk who has turned El
Salvador which in essence was a third
world country I was there about a decade
ago and it was very very dangerous and
run by gangs and there were only certain
streets you could walk down and they had
barbed wire all over the place because
apparently barbed wire does keep bad
people out which is why they keep it at
prisons and things like that and borders
Etc but he has won he's turning the
country around there's a ton of
investment happening in the country it
is way safer right now there's a lot of
good stuff happening in El Salvador
right now I want to show you a couple
headlines on how the mainstream media is
treating this guy headline from the AP
coolest dictator to philosopher king
naib bu's path to reelection in El saor
interesting they called him a dictator
he just won a free and fair election a
headline from CNN in El Salvador
self-styled world's coolest dictator
naib buou heads for re-election amid
human rights concerns he did arrest a
lot of gang members and make the streets
safer but again dictator uh headline
from wapo the inescapable appeal of the
world's coolest dictator uh so as you
know words mean nothing I will throw one
more in for you headline from time
world's coolest dictator naive bu claims
El Salvador presidential reelection so
what this guy did when he came in the
entire country in essence had been run
by gangs quite literally my
brother-in-law was living there about a
decade ago and we went and he was doing
some volunteer work and we went and we
had to we lived or he lived but we were
there for a couple weeks in a in like
this little little community that was
safe barbed wire armed guards everywhere
and they had gangs just all over over
the place you if you walked out there
was a good chance you were going to be
killed certainly mugged or anything else
and that happened all over the country
people people would literally be in
their homes and then the gangs would
just come in kick you out of your home
congratulations the gang own your home
so this guy comes in he he gets the
police and the military to start
actually doing their job they arrest
thousands and thousands of members of
these gangs and now there is Law and
Order and then what happens when you
have Law and Order on the streets and
this is a message in case you're the
mayor of Chicago or of New York City
watching this show when you have Law and
Order on your street and people feel
safe then people are like you know what
maybe I'll open up a business how about
that maybe I'll go to the theater maybe
I'll see what else is happening on the
street and get a slice of pizza and then
economic activity starts happening
people start getting happier they're
flourishing good things start happening
so sort of the reverse of what's
happening in our big cities is what's
happening in El Salvador right now uh
anyway here is video of naib BU who is
being called all of the worst things
right much like Malay in Argentina who
is fighting the media and bringing
capitalism back to his country and
everything else uh here he is talking
about how the regime media lies about
[Music]
him
the
[Music]
or
all right so for those of you listening
on audio in essence what he's saying
there is that we are going to have a
country where we are going to stand up
for the rights of our citizens of people
who are functioning in our society the
way they are supposed to for El
salvadorians you know he said he said
something to the effect of you know
they're criticizing me because of human
rights violations he says human right
violations for who for the for the gang
members so he went in and he cleaned up
his country he claims there I don't know
that it's absolutely true I think it's
at least trending wise true that they
went from the most dangerous country to
the safest country in the Americas I'm
not totally sure that that's absolutely
correct but it certainly is is heading
in that direction you know there's also
something else interesting about it he
has no teleprompter he's 37 years old he
looks like he's going to go bang his
wife after that thing and I actually
think we need some of that energy right
does Joe Biden and Dr Jill Biden please
Trump and like like there're something
about someone that's in the in the
beginnings he's 37 right he's 10 years
younger than me he's in the beginning of
his life he is on the way he has he has
a vested interest in turning this thing
around for his children and everything
else and that's the spirit that
countries are going to need to turn all
of this around but but the bumper
sticker version of what he's saying is
it's the same thing that Aaron Rogers is
saying and it's the same thing that Joe
Rogan's saying yeah yes if you say the
right thing and you do the right thing
and you care about your country and good
people and all those things they will
say mean things about you they will call
you a dictator they will call you a
racist all of that stuff you guys get
all that but it is worth it because at
least you will have your own mind right
and you might have a chance you might
have a chance to do something in this
world but other otherwise you will live
like a slave I want to show you one
other video that that I think is Loosely
related to all of this at least in in
the context of thinking for yourself
there was a video that went viral over
the last couple days of a teacher
debunking a student in real time and
really waking this redpilling this kid
as I said at the top of the show I want
to talk to anyone and talk about anyone
whether it's a football player or a
podcaster or a young kid in this case
whoever it might be that is waking up in
real time because if we can do that we
can solve the problem the problem is not
going to be solved up there down here
it's going to be solved down here and
then we'll fix what's up there right so
check out this is a teacher debunking
just so brilliantly a student who
accuses JK rling of being transphobic
and you know you know about this story
we've covered it quite a bit JK ring all
she has said JK rling who of course
created Harry Potter all she has said is
that you shouldn't have men and women
sports and things along those lines
there's biological differences between
men and women all the stuff that we all
knew was true 10 years ago uh anyway it
has become sort of part of the internet
that she's now transphobic and these
people are trying to write her out of
new Harry Potter stories it's all so
stupid anyway this kid ask the teacher
about JK Rowling's transphobia and
controversial comments and just watch
this so these guys want to talk about JK
Rowling is that so what's going on with
that what do you want to know uh she's
she's had a pretty controversal past I
just want to know like what are your
thoughts on it and like do you still
like her work despite her uh bigoted
opinions so let's get specific though
let's define bigoted opinions what
opinions are bigoted we're going to
treat this as a thought experiment I'm
not going to say what's right or wrong
or what way to think the whole point is
to learn how to think not what to think
yeah so when you say big you you're
you're starting with the conclusion that
given her bigoted opinions so first
let's start with does she have bigoted
opinions so when you when you say big
she has had a history of being extremely
transphobic I've heard you've heard so
what can you give me an example uh if
you look at her Twitter I think you
could see a few things um if you want I
could try and find see if you can find
see if you can find one so one of these
tweets that she came out with in 2019
she said dress however you please call
yourself whatever you like sleep with
any consenting adult who will have you
um live your best life in peace and
security but Force women out of their
jobs for starting that for stating that
sex is real so you find that bigoted
what do you find about it was there it
was deemed
transphobic like I myself do you find
that transf yourself uh I don't really
have an opinion on it but I'm just going
with what a lot of other people have
said okay so we're going to show you a
bit more in just a second but do you see
what this teacher and you know we we can
make fun of teachers all the time and
our education system has been demolished
and we have activists not teachers and
as the teacher points out there too much
too many places of Education are
teaching them to think instead of how to
think but did you see the way he
systematically did that it was a
surgical strike let's get specific
what's bigoted does she actually have
bigoted opinions give me an example so
okay so then he gives the example and
now you can see the kid already is
suddenly waffling well now check this
out so let's pause it let's not go with
what other people are saying let's try
and learn how to critically think so
let's analyze the Tweet ourselves so
that statement do you see anything
problematic disregarding other people's
opinions
um she did try and
pin some things on a spe A specific
group of per of people I where where
dides she do do that can you read that
but Force women out of their jobs for
stating that sex is real so when I hear
that I'm interpreting that as meaning if
a woman says that you know saying that
there's a difference between men and
female
and then being attacked as transphobic I
think that's what she's saying by
attacking someone for stating that sex
is real that is exactly what she's
saying is that transphobic to you
so to me no stating that sex is real is
not transphobic it's just a fact of life
it exists so is there anything you
disagree with in that
tweet uh in that tweet I can't really
see anything that I I myself disagree
with but I can see why some people would
think oh this is offensive we can't have
that here or something cuz do how why do
you do you think it's fair that there's
a that she's being attacked by a large
group of people and people are calling
her like you said at the beginning of
this conversation you said given the
fact that JK rolling is transphobic how
do you feel about Harry Potter now
retroactively looking at that statement
do you think that that was the best way
to phrase no I feel like an idiot now
it's okay though but this is why we do
this to learn to learn how to think do
you see how beautiful that is like
absolutely beautiful when you calmly
question people make them think for
yourselves that's exactly what he was
doing the entire time like why are you
saying these things what do you think
and then by the end the kid is basically
like oh she's not a transphobe and to
connect that to everything else we did
here so it's sort of like maybe Joe
Rogan isn't a racist as CNN was calling
him for months and months and months
maybe Aaron roders isn't anti-science
maybe Elon Musk isn't a Nazi because
he's standing up for free speech and
then I just thought I'd show you this
real quick we're going to put this up in
the studio we just got this yesterday
but I've referenced this many times uh
that is me on the front page so this was
the front page of the Sunday New York
Times on uh Sunday June 9th 2019 so this
is almost five years ago already and
they're they the headline is the making
of a YouTube radical how the s's
algorithms played into the hand of the
alt-right and there's Jordan Peterson
and there's Ben Shapiro and there's Phil
DeFranco and there's Milton fredman and
a whole bunch of people I got a nice big
picture over here that was nice and
there's an entire fake story about how
YouTube was making people turn to the
far right including a whole bunch of us
that have done nothing of the sort of
course at the end the YouTube algorithm
save this kid and he becomes a good
Lefty but the point of all of
that is that they are going to lie and
lie to you they are going to make you
think that that the good guys are the
bad guys and the bad guys are the good
guys but think for yourself and watch
that video of that teacher again so the
next time you are in one of these
conversations with one of your NPC
friends or someone who's in the process
of waking up why do you think that do
you really believe that's true oh did
Donald Trump say very fine people on
both sides do you really believe that
Brett Kavanaugh is a serial rapist Etc
and start questioning really did you do
you think that the vaccine uh actually
stops covid etc etc and if you do that
calmly and everything else without
bludgeoning them and I know it can be
difficult at times and we've all done it
and nobody's perfect at this but then
you can wake more people up and then to
tie this all together then this new
thing that is that is clearly developing
right now this new movement of just
roughly sane people that can agree to
disagree and have different Lifestyles
and all of those things uh but that we
can all be put in a bucket together uh
it might just be the the strongest
political and cultural movement it might
just save the entire West how about that
anyway let's talk about moink box real
quick and then we'll get to a community
Q&A uh 60% of us pork production comes
from one company owned by the Chinese
and their Hogs are given something
called ractopamine which is banned in
160 countries including China yet you
find it in your grocery aisle every day
well guys there's a better way you know
about you know about moink that's moo
plus oink moink delivers grass-fed and
grass finish beef and lamb pastored pork
and chicken and sustainable wild Cod
Alaskan salmon straight to your door
moink Farmers Farm like our grandparents
did and as a result moink meat tastes
like it should because the Family Farm
Does It Better the moink difference is a
difference you can taste and you can
feel good knowing you're helping family
farm stay financially independent as
well you choose the meat delivered in
every box like ribe eyes to chicken
breast to pork chops to salmon fls and
much more plus you can cancel anytime
Shark Tank host Kevin o called moinks
bacon the best bacon he's ever tasted
and they guarantee you'll say oink oink
I'm just so happy I got moinked keep
Amer American farming going by signing
up at moink box.com Ruben right now and
listeners of this show get two free
stakes in the first box it's the best
steak you'll ever taste but for a
limited time that's M inkbox.com rubben
moink box.com
rubben and now back to me all right
Ruben report. locals.com Community Q&A
Brock are you in the chat right now and
we will add a question on the fly if
people want to join us right this very
moment by the way guys you can join
locals absolutely free if you want to
comment get some bonus Stuff Etc a
couple bucks a month that keeps us
independent so I can tell you what I
actually believe as opposed to getting
sponsored by fizer we're not sponsored
by fiser are we that would be weird okay
all right Darren says what's your
favorite season in Florida well Darren I
got to tell you it is it is right now
this period of time this January
February March situation where you wake
up in the morning and it's cool enough
to put on like a light hoodie and take a
walk uh which we try to do every morning
with the boys and with Clyde and then by
the afternoon you you can get in the
pool and it's sunny and we get that
beautiful golden hour at about 6:00 when
the sun's coming down and we get
beautiful colors like I just love it
however I will say that Florida deserves
some credit for the summer I know every
it's hot oh my God it's hot in Florida
in the summer it's so hot yes are there
mosquitoes there are are you going to
sweat you will but you will feel alive I
like walking out there in June or July
middle of the day taking Clyde out and
he's panting and I'm dripping with sweat
and you come back in and you feel
accomplished you feel
alive but yes this period right now is
this is as good as it gets Mitchell says
how did the hardcore carnivore seasoning
turn out so you know I went to this
place there's a there's a wagu place not
too far from the house and I went and I
picked up this really sick Tomahawk I
think we've got a couple pictures here
so that is a a beautiful wagu Tomahawk
and then they had this hardcore
carnivore seasoning these these are not
a sponsor although if they'd like to be
I would gladly take them and what you're
seeing there on the black seasoning I
posted these pictures in locals uh the
black seasoning they put um activated
charcoal in it now I don't think
activated charcoal actually does
anything for the flavor so there's salt
pepper I think they've got a couple of
you know there's probably some garlic
powder onion powder a few other the
classic steak seasonings in there but
the activated charcoal just kind of
makes it look cool so the first picture
you're seeing raw second picture
obviously when I seasoned it I like to
let it sit for like an hour uh obviously
season it on both sides smoked it in the
Big Green Egg and then I seared it
caveman sty which is you just throw it
directly on the coals for about 2
minutes and look how freaking perfect
that thing was it was it was absolutely
delicious absolutely delicious I'm
enjoying uh Hickory Uh Wood seasoning
right now you can mix it up with steaks
uh but Hickory is I'm really nailing
this right now I'm feeling very good
about the barbecue game thanks for
asking the question James says Dave I've
really enjoyed the people of the
internet how's it been working with
Isabelle who's such a young and talented
Creator Brock did you put that question
in there as someone named James um I
absolutely adore Isabelle and when this
opportunity to do this show well
basically tenant came to me and said
what do you want to do you do whatever
you want just let us know and I had this
idea for a show and I had sort of been
thinking you know I've known Isabelle
for three or four years now and we've
done different things over the years and
I was like I want to work with Isabelle
I want to do something a little a little
even though as silly as this show can be
at times I want to do something like a
little more silly and viral and whatever
um I I just adore her I think she's
great she's got an incredible future
ahead of her she has a book coming out
in about uh I think next month if I'm
not mistaken right book's coming out
next month uh Yours Truly wrote the
forward to that thing uh I just love
doing it I think our Vibe is right like
it's just it's just kind of silliness in
the middle of the day uh so if you have
not checked out people in the internet
you should it's we we don't do hardcore
politics a little little cultural stuff
a little politics but it's mostly just
like the
nonsense of of what people are doing on
the internet and there is just a lot of
nonsense people people just spending
time they have a problem and then they
walk into the car they sit down and they
start screaming at the phone those I
find those always to be quite
interesting or I love all the news
person cracking stuff and all that um
but yeah I adore Isabelle and she's
great and I look forward to doing this
for a long time with her Lynn says you
were mentioning a good series to watch
have you watched the bear yet it's on
Hulu excellent another one on Netflix
which you may have seen because it's
older is money Heist but if you haven't
seen it you all have to see it it's
riveting I couldn't stop watching I have
not seen either are you giving a thumbs
up to the bear all right Brock's giv the
thumbs up to the bear have you guys seen
money Heist or the bear nobody else has
seen him I will take that under
advisement right now because we're all
in the midst of this team building
exercise one more time I'll tell you
what happened we said okay that down
with all the guys at dinner I said we're
all going to pick a show and we'll watch
it together over over time that'll be a
team building exercise for all of us
Brock picked a show a Japanese animation
called show called Attack on Titan we
all watched a couple episodes and we
basically pushed it aside I'm sorry he
loves it it's it apparently defined his
whole life but we were just like we
can't take this anymore so now we've
agreed he said okay you don't have to
watch all of Attack on Titan if we can
all watch Barbie together so apparently
we're going to watch Barbie together at
some point so that was his uh Phoenix
has Ozark so we're going to do that
which I have not seen Severance
Severance all right Connor has Severance
which apparently there's only one season
of Joey has peaky blinders which David's
been watching and he wants me to watch
ad has as uh Ted Ted lasso so I guess
we're going for something a little
sillier I haven't seen that and mine is
The Sopranos so stay tuned As We Lay
when when we start each show I'll let
you guys know so you can kind of watch
with with us and we'll do maybe I don't
know like three episodes a week that
kind of thing we'll be doing this
basically till 2044 pretty much Veronica
says uh when you have worked with
someone uh when have you worked with
someone you didn't agree with to solve a
problem or create something what change
in your mindset did you have to get
something accomplish oo that is a that
is a good one um well I'll tell you you
know ultimately when we created locals
it was because I was able to rang
Wrangle together the right people the
right programmers and we got the right
funding and all those things but it took
a long time you know if for those of you
that have been watching the show for at
least five years you know at the height
of the intellectual dark web the IDW
thing when you know Jordan Peterson was
just absolutely exploding rocket fuel
and they're the Weinstein Brothers Sam
Harris and Ben Shapiro and me and Rogan
and a bunch of other people and that
thing was it was just blowing up right
that would lead to the New York Times
you know putting a bunch of us on the
cover saying we're horrible people
because we were just trying to have
conversations and figure out some sanity
um we tried we were trying to figure out
are we a podcast Network are we like a
road touring group like are we going
into politics like what are we all
trying to do and there were a lot of
meetings with agents and with lawyers
and with with all these people like can
we piece this thing together and I think
I've mentioned this once or once or
twice before you know like some people
are a little more like team players like
I like the idea of being part of like a
dream team thing you know I when I play
basketball I like passing I like scoring
too but I like passing some people are
just more like I want to do it my way
and I want to be solo and that's it I
would say that's more of Sam Harris
that's not that in and of itself is not
even a knock on the guy I could knock
the guy for other things that's not a
knock it's just the way some people are
um Jordan was so explosive uh that it
was like how can we even Wrangle this
guy into anything Rogan obviously was
super successful uh Brett was just
coming out of Academia did he want to be
like an internet star so there were all
of these people and these different
selective pressures suffice to say we
never put that together but what I
learned through all of that process was
okay if I have a good idea and my idea
was that creators should be independent
and should own their data and be able to
communicate directly with their audience
and have a slick app and live stream and
no Middleman and all that stuff well
then I'm just going to go ahead and
build it if I can't get the if I can't
get all of the pieces right I'll do it
myself and that's what I did and then of
course the rest is history we end up
merging with Rumble and we're really
building those alternative pipes to the
internet which I'm which we need to say
the least so I would say you start doing
something and if it's if it's something
good you're not going to get it like
it's very rare that it's like just like
a straight shot you know like you see
the thing that you want and that's what
you're going to do whatever especially
if you're building a company it's more
like you see that thing and then a whole
bunch of stuff's going to happen along
the way and then you'll just kind of
directionally build something similar to
it or you'll realize oh maybe that
wasn't the thing I wanted to build I
wanted to build somebody that something
like that and I didn't want to work with
these people I want to work with these
people so uh I would say just do
something just do it did I just come up
with that phrase let's trademark that uh
Harry says if you were president what
would some of your policy aims be for
America well if I was President right
now like right this second close the
border period that's it we have got to
like figure out what the hell is going
on here and we cannot let more people in
uh we know that even before this
craziness of the last three years of the
Biden open border that there were about
12 million illegals here so there are 12
million people here living in the United
States many of them peacefully working
hard all of that stuff but we have to
get a handle on who is here why they're
here what are they doing are they paying
taxes are they in the system to any
degree are they criminals Etc then you
throw in the fact that we've got about
another 6 million so there's probably
it's like 15 to 18 maybe even 20 million
illegals right now no country can can
have that many people that are here
illegally going under the radar even if
not I'm not even saying all the people
are are bad what what were the numbers
you gave me uh you said about uh it's
about so it's they say it's about eight
million it's like six to8 million people
have gotten here under Biden right
illegally now think about it if if 1% of
those people are nefarious or up to no
good or maybe don't like us it's 6
million people 1% that's about 60,000
people that are in the United States
right now I don't know what they're
doing do you so like the Border close
the border number one and figure out
what's going on clean our house first
right that's a Jordan Peterson esque way
of saying it how about we clean our room
and then we'll clean the world after
that if there are people we want to help
outside of our boords we got to clean
the Border first I would say that would
be number one and number two I would say
people people need a little relief and
uh how about a flat tax 15% everybody
pays 15% that's it no state income well
the states could do whatever the hell
they want on President I suppose so
States will do what they want but no uh
just a flat tax for everybody else 37%
you're going to pay to the federal
government it's insane flat tax and you
know what if you make under 50 Grand you
get waved and if you make over 5 million
year we'll tack on another 2% I don't
even think that's moral or legit but
will throw a bone to the progressives
not that they would say that that's
enough but that basically you want a
situation where virtually everybody in
the country except the absolute extremes
are paying the exact same percentage
then people aren't jealous you don't
have class Warfare and then you know
what if the government's not getting as
much money the government will have to
tighten up how about that Joe says is
Taylor Swift a scop so that's like one
of the things that's bubbling online
right now that somehow Taylor Swift and
you know that she's dating uh what's
name on the Chiefs Travis Kelce on the
Chiefs that somehow that this is a s up
because you know she has so many
supporters and young girls and boys that
love her that are just going to be
voting for the first time that she'll go
all in on Biden and you know that that
again you get culture first and then
politics is Downstream from that so the
whole machine is pushing her to get more
young people into the the Democrats I
don't know about that but I will tell
you this I was at Whole Foods the other
day and I'm checking out and you know
they've got the magazine rack there and
it was like six out of the eight
magazines had Taylor Swift's face on the
front how does that possibly make any
sense right now I get it it's a specific
type of person I suppose usually a woman
that is interested in buying a magazine
at checkout so okay it's going to be
it's not just that it's going to be you
know guns and sports and Taylor Swift
and cooking like there's a specific type
of person that but six out of eight were
Taylor Swift on the cover like something
doesn't so I don't know that that makes
it a scop or a grand conspiracy at the
end of the day if she's selling
magazines and she's selling records and
she's selling out concerts and
everything else like people like her
people like her the what was the song
that I know the uh what oh Shake It Up
the girl shakes it up I guess every now
and again uh Mary says how are the boys
doing they must be into everything at
this age about 18 months yeah so
Justin's about 18 Luke's about 16 months
they're just great they're just we did a
little photo shoot with them yesterday
uh Justin's just tearing everything
apart and jumping around and just
constantly nicked here and there and all
you know whatever and throwing things
and everything Luke as I told you guys
he runs a little cooler but now he's
pushing back a little bit more and he's
climbing around his new thing is he
likes to get as high as he possibly can
and then just drop off whatever it is
and it doesn't matter if anyone's there
so I like to try to be there when
possible but like climb to the highest
you know thing on the couch and just
like just just go Um and then he loves
it and he crashes and he loves it and I
was thinking one of the funniest things
about having kids is that kids fall so
many times a day so the I don't know
someone's I'm sure done a study on this
but if you took like a one or a
two-year-old this kid once they start
walking they must fall 80 or 100 times a
day right they're just walking and they
fall they trip over something and they
fall they the dog knocks them over they
just fall all the time and then they
just get up and they keep going think
about an adult any of you guys if you
fell once during the day if you just
fell once your day is ruined you oh and
then you're going to complain about it
to my hip hurts my like you fall on your
face once that's it but something about
being a kid you can just you take your
licks and you keep go keep on going and
that is the human spirit that we all
need right now but they're doing great
and thank you for asking the question uh
Angela says uh will you be taking part
in any of Jordan Peterson's new wrestle
with God lectures I purchased VIP meet
and greets to his June 9th show in DC so
excited yes we are figuring out
something to do a live show with him at
one of uh the the on location venues as
part of the tour I don't know which one
it is maybe it will be DC but good for
you getting the the meet and greet you
know he does a great job because he does
he does the full-on lecture then he does
a smaller chat it's usually about a 100
people and you will get at least 30
seconds with him and everybody wants to
tell him their life story and how he
helped them and everything else I would
say be brief and succinct and look him
right in the eye and just get to it and
thank him and he he hears all those
stories like I mean I mean it literally
and figuratively like he hears them and
it means something to him and uh and I
think it fuels him to keep going so uh
that's great that you're going uh da
says uh was the Border Bill bad or not I
think it was bad but now they're going
to blame Trump yet again yeah it was bad
uh we we went into it with a couple of
the Senators that we talked about or
that I interviewed look they were going
to let in 1.8 million illegals a year
what what kind of Bill do you sign that
tells you how many people are allowed to
break the law that you're signing we
also don't need a new law to close the
border the president can do it right now
actually even this morning on Twitter
they're starting to talk about
apparently the Biden ad Administration
is leaking that they might do some
executive actions on the border so the
same people that a month ago told us
there was no crisis then want to put on
this ridiculous bipartisan bill which
bipartisan just means everyone's getting
screwed and now they're suddenly like oh
I guess the president could do something
about this all of that to be said the
Democrats you got to give the devil his
due and what by this bill being killed
you can already feel what's going to
happen what this is exactly what's going
to happen mark my words Conor do we have
some sort of way we can make a note of
this episode at this very moment you
have some on the computer that can do
that uh what they are going to do is
something bad is going to happen this is
my prediction something bad some sort of
terror attack or something is going to
happen because of illegals before the
election and then what the Democrats and
the mainstream media are going to do is
say well you see what happened we tried
to get a bipartisan bill out there and
you Republicans didn't vote for it so
look what happened and the media and the
Dems will lay the blame well they'll lay
the blame on Trump right because they're
saying well Trump doesn't want it to
happen because if the Democrats got the
Border fixed then Trump wouldn't have
anything to run on that doesn't make the
bill good there actually is some truth
to that right if Biden started doing
good things as a president right if
Biden started I don't know getting rid
of Regulation if Biden started having a
cohesive foreign policy if Biden started
taking care of the Border there would be
less reason to vote for Trump I don't
think he's going to do any of those
things but I think they will figure out
ways to blame things on Republicans and
Trump and and by the Republicans killing
the bipartisan deal which again I'm
saying is a bad deal it is a bad deal
read it for yourself 5,000 illegal can
come in a day 1.8 million a year and
that's only for Mexico non-contiguous
Nations so like China for example if
you're from a non-contiguous nation and
you get through a China then you don't
even count at all so it would be an
unlimited amount of those people like
only DC could come up with this but it
will be used the the killing of the bill
will be used against the Republicans uh
on Election time cat says what's a skill
that you want to learn um you know we're
building out a big Garden situation here
like a a 15x 40ft garden situation and
we're also I'm I'm working on putting in
a bigger we had a little chicken cpop
when we were in uh in Cali I want to do
a chicken cpop situation like a little
composting things I want to do a little
more of the homesteading thing in
general like I just want to be I'm not
going to be off the grid living in Miami
and I don't want to be like fully fully
Off the Grid at least at the moment um
but just being able to really do more
things and know that if if the hit
the fan uh that we could really take
care of ourselves and and all those
things so I'm really you know we've done
little gardening thing and it's it's
obviously pretty easy to grow stuff here
in Florida especially Citrus and that
kind of stuff uh but we're going to do
some potatoes we're going to do some
lettu uses things of that nature the
waste we'll give it to the chickens the
like I'm looking forward to a little bit
of maybe we'll do a little uh we'll do
an episode in a chicken coop how does
that sound pretty good truski says uh
why are the Jewish people hating so much
Nazi Germany Hamas Etc what have they
done so heinous that so many people want
them removed from Humanity it's called
surviving it's as simple as that Thomas
Soul uh we've played a video of him
talking about this about 30 years ago
it's called surviving and excelling uh
Jews by and large despite being a
minority had Traditions had family had a
culture all of those things and it was
always a little bit of outside the norm
and then through through family and
traditions and culture figured out how
to largely succeed in the ways that you
want to succeed in the west and people
look at others I mean this is just a
human condition people look at others
and they think well why do they have
what we don't have so it's a it's a
weird jealousy thing and one of when you
know a year year and a half ago when
Kanye was at like the height of his
lunacy he basically said that on on one
of I think it was on Tim pool's podcast
he was like well the Jews have succeeded
and I want that for my community and
it's like okay well you can get that for
your community you might want to
replicate some of the things that
they've done rather than trying to kill
these people or take them out or
demonize them um so there's a particular
lead um I would say Insidious version of
this when it comes to Israel because
Israel they not only have they succeeded
and thrived and taken a desert and made
it Bloom and all of those things but
they also have weapons they're also not
subjugated by other people and that
makes them doubly hated by these people
but I would say more than anything else
it's not a zero sum game like you
shouldn't anyone that you look at that
that has more than you and by the way
there are plenty of Jews that don't have
more and everything else but if you're
looking at a group of people and being
like they seem to do it right right why
is it where when they move to a
community the communities get cleaner or
nicer or safer or what is it about that
community that oh their families are
more intact or whatever it's not Zero
Sum you shouldn't be like oh we have to
destroy those people so we can have
those things it's oh maybe there's some
ideas there that you might want to
replicate like that's actually how it
works or should work uh Meg says every
once in a while maybe monthly could we
have a show with just Good things/ Winds
happening around the world that would be
a nice idea all right we are going going
to is there anything good happening in
the world today anything does anyone any
of you have any good news in your own
lives someone say something positive
about the world what are we having for
lunch thank you we're having right all
right
that's no no just good all right we're
gonna find some good things no one's
giving me anything good at the moment
but we will find I like the idea yeah
the problem is that people don't respond
that much to good things you know I try
to tie the show in like a positive way
at the end but you know if you people
don't it's why the news they just you
ever watch the local news this woman got
raped that man fell into a vat of acid
this six cats were burned alive and it's
like why are you watching this people
but for some reason people do uh all
right we got to do this quick now uh
because we're doing a little photo shoot
after uh Stephen says if you were
Trump's campaign manager what would your
best piece of advice be for him and why
well look it's it's an unwinable job and
it's a thankless job to be a campaign
manager for Donald Trump because he's
going to do whatever the hell he wants
whether it comes to the legal cases or
the media or anything else but I have
said this since I've I've always said
this but right now the one thing you
need Trump is all of these people like
Rogan who didn't vote for you last time
there's every reason to believe they
could vote for you Aaron roders all
these people waking up there's all the
reasons they could vote for you but you
got to just take a little bit off the
top right you got to just ease up on the
oh that's an ugly woman and this guy's
stupid and all of that stuff not to say
it can never be there and no one it's
hard to tell the guy who's done the
thing that no one said he could do it's
hard to tell him how to do things right
so it's not that I have some great
Insight on this but the fundamental
truth is there's so many people waking
up right now but they are still there's
either a level of TDS or they just and
it and it's largely uh Suburban
middle-aged women they will not vote for
Trump and a lot of them don't want to do
it because they don't want because they
don't see Trump as a good role model
because of the way he speaks and
everything imagine if he just started
like toning it down a little little bit
a little bit and he could even say you
know I'm going to tone it down a little
bit right now you guys get what I am
like I think there's a way he could
level up I don't know that he has it in
him but I think there would be a way to
do it Mia says uh I've noticed you've
been reacting to a lot of South Park
scenes on your Show recently what do you
think of South Park as a show so this
all happened because my guys all love
South Park and they they cannot believe
that I had never seen South Park I told
you I was a Simpsons guy I couldn't do
two cartoons it was just how it was so
we've been doing these videos that
people are absolutely loving I mean
South Park like it's wacky as hell it is
extremely Politically Incorrect like you
watch it the whole time you're watching
it you're basically like what is about
to happen because you know something
crazy is going to happen and then it's
always crazier than what you think is
going to happen uh so it's funny as hell
and at some point I would like to start
watching it a little more contiguously
rather than Ju Just these little clips
that we're showing but I'm glad people
seem to be uh seem to be digging these
things guys my full interview with ran
Paul from DC at the new Rumble studio is
up right now part two with Ben Shapiro
up across platforms uh that also is uh
well all my stuff is early as always on
Ruben report. locals.com uh we leave you
with another news blooper and I will see
you on people of the internet in about
an hour ciao check your panties about
175,000 rice I think that was supposed
to be
[Laughter]
[Music]
pantries